und mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt die eu
kommissionspräsidenten ursula von der
leyen guten morgen nach brüssel guten
morgen frau von der leyen sprechen wir
zuerst über das thema energie die eu
kommission hat gestern einen plan
vorgelegt mit dem russischen gasimporte
innerhalb eines jahres um zwei drittel
reduziert werden sollen bundeskanzler
scholz aber sagt wir können vorerst
nicht auf russisches gas verzichten wie
passt das zusammen
eines ist ganz klar wir müssen unbedingt
raus aus der abhängigkeit von russischem
gas und in der tat wir haben schon
gezeigt in den letzten sechs wochen dass
wir es schaffen können sehr viel
schneller diese unabhängigkeit zu
erreichen und auf russisches gas zu
verzichten erstens haben wir überall auf
der welt die anderen verlässlichen
anbieter von gas gebeten mehr so
genanntes lng gas flüssiggas zu liefern
und das ist in den letzten sechs wochen
deutlich angestiegen diese lieferungen
so dass wir jetzt zum beispiel sagen
können wir sind unabhängig von
russischem gas bis zum ende dieses
winters
zweitens ganz wichtig gemeinsame
speicher anliegen auch über andere
zulieferer weltweit die bereit sind in
diese lücke des russischen gases dann zu
stoßen das dritte ist entscheiden
massive investitionen in erneuerbare
energien
denn diese erneuerbaren energien werden
zu hause bei uns produziert schaffen bei
uns zuhause arbeitsplätze und geben uns
die unabhängigkeit die wir wollen und
dann schlussendlich gibt es einen punkt
den möchte ich unbedingt auch nennen
nämlich die tatsache dass wir alle dazu
beitragen können unabhängiger zu werden
von russischem gas überhaupt von den
fossilen brennstoffen indem wir energie
sparen jeder und jeder an seinem platz
kann dieses tun natürlich gibt es auch
sparprogramme die deutlicher weiter
greifen in die wirtschaft hinein und
wenn wir alles das kombinieren also
andere lieferer von gas erneuerbare
energien energiesparen und sinnvoll klug
einsetzen dann können wir sehr viel
schneller unabhängig vom russischen gas
verkauf von der leyen sie hören sich
aber auf jeden fall optimistischer an
als der bundeskanzler bei diesem thema
und viele verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher fragen sich natürlich was
das für die energiepreise bedeutet angst
dass die nach oben schießen ja und
deshalb dass ein war jetzt eben gas das
andere thema was sie zu recht
angesprochen haben ist zum beispiel öl
deshalb haben wir mit unseren
amerikanischen freunden sehr genau die
sanktionen abgestimmt für uns ist
wichtig dass jeder das rein bringt in
die sanktion damit putin seinen krieg
nicht mehr finanzieren kann wo man am
meisten
dieser kriegsführung durch putin schadet
uns selber aber nicht schadet und wenn
sie sich mal die letzten 13 tage
anschauen putins krieg in den letzten 13
tagen wir haben ein sanktionspaket auf
den weg gebracht an tag 2 14 und an tag
6 und wenn wir uns jetzt die
auswirkungen anschauen eine woche weiter
dann sehen wir der rubel ist in freiem
fall hat 50 prozent seines wertes
verloren gegenüber des gegenüber dem
euro wir sehen dass die zinsen durch die
decke gehen wir sehen dass die rat dass
die ratingagenturen die russischen
staatsanleihen als sogenanntes junk
beurteilen also schrott im prinzip sie
haben jetzt die inflation an unterstützt
wenn ich das sagen da drauf und anlagen
etc sie sagen ist wenn ich kurz ein
haken darf sie haben es erwähnt aber die
frage war ob die energiepreise nach oben
gehen für die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher
und die der punkt ist mir wichtig also
wir haben die die sanktions pakete so
geschnitten dass wir maximale wirkung in
russland erreichen ohne uns zu sehr zu
schaden und dazu gehört dann eben auch
dass die amerikaner besser auf die
öllieferungen aus russland verzichten
können als wir das können und sie haben
ganz recht wir müssen immer im blick
behalten dass die ölpreise nicht zu sehr
eskalieren nicht zu sehr ansteigen denn
das wiederum würde uns schwächen und
deshalb dieses feine austarieren mit
unseren freunden übrigens inzwischen
sind es über 40 länder die sich den
sanktionen angeschlossen haben das ist
ganz ganz wichtig um maximale wirkung zu
erreichen bei präsident putin aber bei
uns keinen schaden anzurichten frau von
der leyen ein weiteres großes thema ist
natürlich die situation der geflüchteten
aus der ukraine nach un-angaben haben
seit kriegsbeginn mehr als zwei
millionen menschen inzwischen das land
verlassen bisher und auch während des
syrien krieges konnte man von einer
gemeinsamen flüchtlingspolitik in der eu
ja nicht wirklich sprechen ist das jetzt
anders
ich finde es ist überwältigend positiv
wie die 27 mitgliedsstaaten ganz
deutlich signalisieren offene arme die
geflüchteten sind willkommen wir tun
alles um sie zu schützen alle die die
aus der ukraine flüchten haben sofort
residenz rechte hier das heißt sie
können den zugang zum arbeitsmarkt haben
natürlich medizinische versorgung den
unterhalt die kinder können zur schule
gehen und das sind alle mitgliedsstaaten
die da mitmachen besonders beeindruckend
sind die staaten die direkt an der
grenze sind das ist polen das es ungarn
das ist rumänien die slowakei die mit
aller kraft diese flüchtlinge jetzt
aufnehmen ich fürchte das ist erst der
anfang wir werden sehr viel höhere
zahlen noch nehmen aber ich finde es
zutiefst beeindruckend welche
aufnahmebereitschaft herrscht und wie
geschlossen und geeint die europäische
union da steht das ist übrigens in die
sagen ganzen auseinandersetzung unsere
ganz ganz große stärke wir sind
geschlossen und wir handeln schnee frau
von der leyen wenn sie schon bei uns in
der sendung sind ganz kurz noch und mit
der bitte um eine kurze antwort beim öl
sind wir abhängig von russland beim gas
auch bei der sicherheit sind wir
abhängig von der usa sind sie dafür eine
schlagkräftige europäische armee
aufzubauen ich habe ja immer sehr dafür
gearbeitet dass wir eine verteidigungs
union tatsächlich auch haben und eine
europäische armee hieße das die
verschiedenen mitgliedstaaten ihre
anteile in so etwas hineingeht deshalb
eine armee der europäer ist eigentlich
der richtige der bessere begriff für
meine vorstellung aber dass wir
investieren müssen in verteidigung dass
wir gemeinsam investieren müssen dass
wir gemeinsame ausbildung und
fähigkeiten entwickeln müssen ist gar
keine frage das ist etwas das hat uns
auch putins krieg gezeigt was ganz oben
auf der tagesordnung steht vielen dank
für das gespräch die eu
kommissionspräsident in ursula von der
leyen dankeschön